what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special to offer and
I love to see it explode
so that you can help change the planet
so to help you on your journey today I'm
gonna look at seven of the fastest ways
to grow a YouTube channel so one of the
questions I get asked a lot by people
want to start a YouTube channel that's
Evan how do I grow how do I get it going
fast I want to get lost subscribers and
want to get a lot of growth I want to be
able to make money have an impact with
my channel what's the fastest way to get
there so today I'm gonna share with you
with the help of my friends the seven
different ways to quickly grow your
YouTube channel hey guys my name is Tim
Schmoyer and I run a YouTube channel
called video creators for every week are
publishing a new videos to help you guys
learn how to grow an audience on YouTube
so you can spread a message that reaches
people and changes their lives a lot of
creators when they start off trying to
grow YouTube channel they usually think
in terms of creating really amazing high
production video quality content and
that is certainly very important but
they sometimes sacrifice that for not
thinking as much about like what's going
to get people to actually watch their
video in the first place
Derral is gonna be here with you guys in
a second talk about thumbnails but
titles are also very important I know a
lot of top level creators on YouTube who
spend just as much time crafting their
titles as they do the actual content
itself because they've realized that
doesn't matter how amazing the content
is if the title doesn't tease a story or
delitzsch some value that the person
that they're trying to reach with their
video actually wants to consume in the
first place so definitely spend a lot of
time learning about headlines searching
google for forhow magazines and blogs
craft titles and learning about like in
the news industry they the same thing
they've learned that titles get clicks
titles is what gets people to read their
content or in your case watch your
content so learn as much as you can
about crafting a really good content
and really especially really good titles
[Music]
tip number two is post more frequently I
saw a huge jump in my subscribers in my
views in my revenue when I went from
making one video week to a video a day a
massive jump YouTube seems to really
really really care about upload
frequency especially right now I saw
another massive jump going from one
video a day to two videos a day and I'm
at 3 videos a day most days and there
was a little bit of a jump between 2 and
3 is a little bit of a job so I would
say if you're one video day or two
videos a day you're getting the maximum
leverage out of it and then it starts to
fall off now that may not be possible
for you right now you may be look at
that so this is crazy like making a
video a month is hard enough for me
that's okay to be where you are right
now I would look at how do I start to
increase my frequency with the goal of
getting to one video a day at least one
video they should be the new bare
minimum if you want to have success in
2017 as a YouTube creator if you look at
my channel if you look at Gary's channel
if you look at Grant Cardone channel if
you look at a lot of different YouTube
creators they saw their growth just
explode when they went to making daily
content it's just something that YouTube
cares about right now may not be the
same case in a year or two years from
now but right now if you are making
daily content even if it's worse content
than your competitors you will win
because it's what YouTube favors at the
moment
[Music]
hi I'm Sean kennel with video
influencers and tip number three is tap
into the power of YouTube live now
YouTube lives actually been around for a
while now you could go live with a
streaming device from your computer you
could use Google Hangouts and go on
YouTube live but it wasn't until this
year that they added the ability to
simply go live just from the mobile app
on your phone and this presents a big
opportunity for you and for me as
creators so there's really three big
reasons why I think it's important to
tap into the power of YouTube live and
the first one is it can add videos to
your weekly upload schedule like this is
a big deal right because the demand of
how many times we should upload per week
to get favored with YouTube get favored
with the algorithm stay engaged with our
audiences is getting higher and higher
every day I'm hearing people saying at
least be posting three videos a week I
know Evan says post two to three videos
a day right so the demand and how many
times we should be uploading is going
higher and the nice thing about YouTube
live it is it allows us to do more
uploads I mean it's a it's a finalized
video once the video is done going live
per week in a simple manner no editing
you know less production and things like
that you know I think the second big
reason that YouTube live is so powerful
is it creates depth with your audience
you know edited videos are great but
sometimes they don't show off as much of
our personality as going live does and
so it live allows you for the chance to
do q and A's have people to get to know
you better and just kind of see you in a
real minute four-minute unscripted
unedited context and then the third huge
reason that you need to be using YouTube
live is it is a chance to grow your
audience and here's how if you actually
think about your live stream and the
video optimization ahead of time then
your lives can rank while you're live
even if they don't rank later let me
explain what I just said so if you think
about a title like I helped with YouTube
tips on my channel so maybe how to get
more subscribers on your YouTube channel
like a very searchable thoughtful
optimized
title from our studies and we've done
probably over 50 of these we've noticed
that even if that video doesn't rank for
that title on the replay that it
actually is usually number one or number
two for the time while the video is live
so for if the live stream is about an
hour that video is at the top of search
for like an hour and what we've noticed
is when your live stream is over we
actually see the subscriber growth it
says the channel grew by 10 subscribers
who grew by 20 subscribers and even
during our lives we've tested this and
said hey how long you been a part of the
video influencers community and some
people will say I just found you right
now does that make sense so the key is
if you think about an optimized
searchable title what people are
actually typing in and search and you
title your live stream that before you
go live you have the chance to meet new
people and grow your audience during the
time of that live stream if not beyond
that as well if the video continues to
be ranked high in youtube search ok so I
hope you're convinced that you should be
doing live streams every week and I want
to just give you one power tip for
YouTube live and that is this always go
live with the replay in mind because one
of the most powerful things about live
is not just the people who join you live
but the fact that there's gonna be a
rebroadcast there's gonna be a video
that lives on your channel forever if
you leave it public and so I think the
biggest tip here is there's a lot of
things you could do with the replay in
mind but I just like to over communicate
at the beginning assuming that people
are coming that aren't they're live and
what I mean is I still open up the video
with a strong hook by declaring you know
saying out loud what the topic is about
or leading with a qualifying question
and then I also like to even explain
what people can expect so I might say
something like you know this video is
gonna be about 20 minutes of content
that I have for you guys about 5 points
and then it's gonna be Q&A so if you're
watching on the replay you can know that
these first 20 minutes you can get all
the points and if you want to hang out
will do you know you can re-watch the
Q&A that will last for about another 40
minutes if the live stream you know is
really long and so the point is over
communicate and
- not just the live audience but also
speak to your replay audience and then
the lifespan of your YouTube live can be
a lot longer than just the people who
watch live and you can hook the interest
of replay viewers so whether you go live
from your computer or whether you just
grab your smartphone and go live from
your mobile device I encourage you to
try to go live at least once a week or
more with valuable content to grow your
brand and I expect that you'll see
powerful results hey it's Jeremy mess
from vidpow comm tip number four is how
to optimize your videos for
discoverability the most important
ranking factor on YouTube is watch timer
how long someone watches your video most
YouTube channels get their most organic
traffic through the suggested videos on
the right-hand side means your
thumbnails and title should be really
really awesome
my favorite thumbnail title combo is
from Vsauce he just has a yellow box and
the title says this is not yellow that
intrigue is absolutely brilliant and
he's got over 17 million organic views
on that video a few things I like to do
to make our thumbnail stand out is to
use a brand or a color pattern or a logo
on all your video thumbnails what this
does is it creates a pattern on the
right hand side suggested videos so that
the brain sees all of your branded
thumbnails if it's in position 3 7 or 9
it just visually sees them all and your
viewers are more likely to click on your
thumbnail another thing I like to do is
think of the three E's eyes eyes are the
subconscious window to the soul and do
help with people clicking on your
thumbnails emotion try to paint a
picture with your thumbnail if something
exciting is happening make sure that
that is featured on the thumbnail and
excitement you want to make sure your
thumbnails exciting to give someone a
reason to click on it I highly recommend
saturating and pumping up the colors
about 30 or 40 percent more than normal
so that when you zoom that thumbnail
down real small it's not bland it really
pops
the thing I like to do is sharpen and
Photoshop I use the unsharpened filter
mask I sharpen a lot more than natural
again so that when the thumbnail is
really small it's a little crisper than
the competitors thumbnails next to you
and for titles I like to start typing in
the youtube search box to see what auto
populate typically this is the most
searched for term and should give you a
lot of great ideas on what people are
actually searching for in YouTube you
want to balance the title with keyword
rich information people are searching
for with a reason to click on the video
and I also like to use broader topics so
if you have a hundred tutorials on
hairstyles you want to make sure you add
the word hairstyle waterfall braids so
that you start ranking for what the
video is about and also the broader
category in which the video is in
another great way to get discovered on
YouTube is to collab as much as you
possibly can
[Music]
hi I'm Matt Gillan founder and CEO of
little monster me echo where we help
people build audiences primarily on
YouTube but really across social one and
tip number five is to make videos that
are between seven and sixteen minutes in
length and really the sweet spot is
about 10 to 12 minutes so we think about
the algorithm essentially the way we
like to think about it is that the
algorithm takes in feedback from the
audience
and based on that feedback through their
actions on YouTube and the time they
spend on YouTube YouTube tries to
provide them with the best experience to
keep them on the site for the longest
and I think what the algorithm has found
at least currently is that videos that
are between 7 and 16 minutes in length
are delivering those long as session
times in our research that we published
right around VidCon which is titled
cracking YouTube in 2017 what we found
was that videos that were 7 to 16
minutes in length
and the best viewership as a percentage
of their own subscribers on the first
day second day seven day and thirty day
in fact on the seven day and thirty day
it was fifty percent higher than videos
that were shorter in length and around
25 percent higher than videos that were
longer than 16 minutes what we looked at
after that was the average view duration
of those same videos and we were looking
at about seventy seven thousand videos
across eleven hundred channels all
topics all Nisha's so I think it's a
pretty good sample size for YouTube and
basically what we found was that videos
have achieved a average view duration of
five to eight minutes were the ones that
were doing the best across those same
time ranges and those average view
duration really look like a big curve
and essentially videos that got shorter
our review average view duration didn't
get as many views in any of those four
time frames the videos that were longer
for the most part got a little bit less
on average and so what I think this
indicates to us is that the audience has
shown the algorithm and then the
algorithm reinforces that by feeding
them back suggestions based on that that
essentially videos that are shorter lead
to shorter sessions in part because
every time someone's made forced to make
a choice on YouTube they're forced to
make the choice of whether or not to
leave YouTube and go somewhere else like
Reddit and for videos that are longer
people might be making the decision to
leave YouTube because they've already
invested a significant amount of time in
watching video there and so it's really
hard to as a creator or as an editor to
say I want to make a video that gets a 5
to 8 minute at review duration however
you can't do some back on napkin
as a pertain to your channel so if you
regularly put up videos that are 10
minutes online and you get a 40% average
view duration which is a little bit low
oh your videos are gonna be doing about
4 minutes in terms of average view
duration and that's gonna be on the
lower end however if you can make a 15
minute video that's just as entertaining
and you still get that 40 percent you
know now you're looking at you know
getting into that 5 to 8 minute range
kind of sweet spot where you're gonna
get the most views as a percentage of
your subscribers on the first day and
the second day and the 7th in up to 30
days hi my name is Peter Hollens I am an
acapella singer on YouTube and also the
founder of the Hollande's creator
Academy right now in 2017 the fastest
way to grow a YouTube channel is to do
your homework you have to be able to do
the research and development and look
for the 5 to 10 people online on YouTube
and even on other platforms that are
creating the exact same similar type of
content that you want to make I'm sorry
to break it to you but you are not a
hundred percent unique and innovative
anymore there is always somebody else
out there that is making similar content
to you and it is your job to be able to
understand how they got to where they
are why are they successful how often do
they upload how do they community manage
are they responding to every single calm
comment how are they monetizing their
content their brand that they're putting
out there are they also running a
secondary business so that that's where
they're getting their money most people
can't make a living off of just ad
revenue right we are now dealing in an
age where we are trying to get people's
attention right the metric that we need
to pay attention to is how often you can
keep somebody's attention you want to
get it for as long as possible right so
how are these people keeping people's
attention how are they making money how
are they communicating with their
audience how often are they uploading
and even break it down to how are these
people uploading and making their
content what makes it special it
behooves you when you start to
coppy Picasso said good artists copy but
great artists steal don't be afraid when
you're starting to use somebody else's
algorithm and make it your own
in the beginning give them give them you
know give them credit in the description
but start there
ok so reverse engineer your big idea
find those five to ten people find out
what they're doing why they're
successful and make it your own good
luck
[Music]
hi I'm Daryl eaves and tip number seven
is make your thumbnails more clickable a
lot of content creators put a lot of
energy and time into their video but the
overlooks something that is completely
important for their success here on
YouTube the most top performing videos
that ever occurred on YouTube are using
custom thumbnails and by creating a
custom thumbnail he gives you the
opportunity to really showcase what your
video is going to be so let me give you
a couple tips how to make your
thumbnails more clickable before you
actually pick up the camera to start
shooting your content that you're
thinking about something you're thinking
about the thumbnail what thumbnail would
be engaging how can it relate to the
video content and so on next is a really
important factor is you need to think
mobile more and more people are
accessing YouTube around the world on
mobile devices so you need to think okay
this needs to look good on mobile and
and to when you're actually designing
this custom thumbnail that you are
putting it to the size of how someone
would see it on a mobile device next you
need to make your thumbnail actually
stand out because really there's a lot
of competition on YouTube when someone
is actually searching and see a myriad
of results of videos or they're watching
a video and they see hey here's all the
different things for suggestion or
they're on the Browse feature on their
mobile device there's a lot of
competition what we what our goal is is
to really pull in the potential viewer
say oh this is interesting enough this
makes sense
see more and when they see more that's
when you actually get the view now let
me give you a perfect example of this
now a client that I work with is Studio
C just amazing youtubers and here are
two different types of thumbnails now
the first one is a great type of
thumbnail and a lot of people would be
very satisfied with this thumb now
because it has all the right features
you know we have the law of thirds that
you're able to see from there and then
to you know it's very engaging and it's
telling a story which is really really
important but if this video is competing
with 20 different types of videos how
can we make it stand out even further
well in this example is how we optimized
the thumbnail and you're able to see the
color pulls it in we actually have
something that kind of explains even
more than just the title would and it's
really talking about what's in the video
and it gives people more curious about
what's going on
now besides the law of thirds and adding
color to your thumbnails and really
pulling people in your thumbnail should
tell a story now in this example Team
Edge has competitions that are going on
and this is a standalone thumbnail with
no title and it tells a story of what's
going to actually happen in the video
now I'm going to show you an example of
something really simple but it's
probably the most important thing about
clickable thumbnails is your clickable
thumbnail should be complimentary to
your title it needs to be a clickable
title and they work together now I'm
gonna give you a really simple example
of this and it you don't need to
overcomplicate this so here's a great
thumbnail which is the color yellow and
a great title which is this is not
yellow these complement each other you
can see the simplistic results that
Vsauce actually did but it's the
strategy it's really thinking about it
before you actually create your content
it's also taking time when you're
creating your video to set up shots for
the thumbnail and to you know really
thinking about how the thumbnail and
title come together to really tell the
story and that
how you actually have more success on
YouTube because what happens when you
have a great thumbnail and a great title
that are clickable
people will start clicking on it and
based on your content the time that you
actually spend on your content you know
and they they retain on the video
YouTube will actually promote you more
this is the way it is and this is how
you have success so thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed and
thank you so much to all my friends who
contributed their expertise these are
the people I look up to and the YouTube
world as well and I really appreciate
them spending some time to share their
tips with you I'd love to know what do
you guys think what did you take from
this video what lesson was most
applicable to what you're doing in your
channel share your thoughts down in the
comments below if there's an 8 9 10 that
I missed that you want to add leave it
below as well and if you want to vote on
what seven ways video I do next check
out the link in the description you can
go there have your say and I might just
do it in the next edition finally when
they give a quick shoutout to Tim
Schmoyer who started off this video Tim
was also kind enough to provide a blurb
for the back of my book your one word
and then he shared it on Instagram so
Tim I really appreciate all the love and
support I hope you enjoyed the book it
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon